all right everybody we are live now
streaming on rumble
on youtube and on blaze tv i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message it's october
27th and yeah yesterday was a huge day
we announced the big rumble
locals merger acquisition
it's been a little haywire around here
been doing a lot of press did tucker
last night was on with bongino this
morning a whole bunch more
tomorrow is our thursday q a and i will
answer as many questions because i know
a gajillion questions are coming in
asking about the tech the legal aspects
how we're dealing with speech stuff
decentralization issues all of the stuff
and one of the reasons that i wanted to
partner with rumble in the first place
is because these guys want to be as
transparent as possible which is what
we've tried to do with locals when it
comes to our policies and everything
else
that's why i'm sticking around i didn't
just sell the company and walk i am
staying on
as a part of the public face and and to
guide policy on the company going
forward and bongino and i and several
other people
who will come out of the woodwork soon
enough uh will try to communicate all of
the policies as clearly and cleanly as
possible to you guys um so tomorrow when
we do our thursday q a i will get to
more of your questions and and tons of
them have been coming in so if you want
to get your questions in you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com and by the way
we do have live chat going on right now
if you want to chat live during the show
without bots without trolls without
crazy psychotic internet lunatics
reubenreport.locals.com and of course
there is an ios
iphone app and a droid app as well
before we get to anything though today i
just saw something so horrific
so profoundly disturbing
so
rotten to the core something that would
make you want to jump out of a window
and i thought i should show it to the
audience take a look
when was the last time
was that just the worst thing that
you've ever seen yeah that was terry
mcauliffe who is this really horrible
democrat who's running for governor of
virginia and of course he's calling the
other guy uh racist and all that he's
standing next to joe biden who's the guy
pretending to be president they don't
have masks on and just look at these
people dancing it's hard
[Music]
when was the last time
they're so human aren't they human the
way they move they're so human and they
like to dance it's just why did i do
that to you i've ruined your day i
thought my day was ruined why can't i
ruin everybody else is they absolutely
horrible but it was making me think you
know i often say
how uh remember the orange guy trump
with the hair and everything and the
funny way he tweeted um he would dance
at a lot of his rallies and i always
would say that trump somehow despite
being a billionaire orange man was more
authentic than all of the democrats if
you just look at all of the democrats
they're so deeply inauthentic all of the
people who are running last time whether
it's biden who doesn't know where he is
or p buddha judge who's just doing an
impression of obama or elizabeth warren
i'm gonna get me a beer and she also
pretended to be native american to get a
job like these people are such frauds
although i will give bernie credit like
he truly is like an old socialist
curmudgeon that is bernie sanders
there's no doubt about it but i was
thinking even trump dancing is more
authentic than these people
[Music]
tell me you don't miss that man with the
hand pumps and the pointing
and the whole thing it's like that's him
dancing
one more time just watch
ugh mcauliffe
when's the last time we drop
all right all right enough of that
enough i i miss trump these people are
just all horrible anyway we got three
stories for you today uh desantis ron
desantis who i had dinner with on friday
night at a fundraiser in san francisco i
went up to the dystopian hellhole that
is san francisco i mean it really is
quite horrible uh but i was at a pretty
exclusive fundraiser for ron desantis
for the record before the haters get in
i did not have to pay because i'm
obviously going to interview him at some
point and i felt that would be unethical
so i was able to get in otherwise um but
i think he's a great guy and and i
listened to him talking he was just
great throw the picture up of the two of
us it was just it was just a really
great night and as i said on monday when
we originally showed that image it was
just so nice to be listening to a
politician who actually was talking
about america in a decent way and
talking about
choice and not crushing you in every way
possible and welcoming police officers
and nurses to his state if they can't
get work in other states because of
these draconian mandates and everything
else he was just
a freaking decent guy and he took every
question that anyone could ask he was he
was just great so anyway so desantis has
just about had it with the infallible
fouchy so he really went off on him
because of the dogs that we covered the
dog story we covered a couple days ago
and just generally what's going on with
the mandate so we'll talk about that
then uh if you didn't realize it they
are coming for your children you know
like i get it you're just gonna go along
a lot of not you my audience because i
know you guys aren't and you're fighting
and you're trying and by the way i feel
some momentum now don't you feel a
little a little bit of momentum like it
feels like maybe we're getting some wins
here i mean it because of partly because
of the deal
yesterday the big rumble locals deal but
i also mean like parents are starting to
fight back like good people are pushing
back like something good's happening
here well they're coming for your kids
they're coming for your kids the fda is
now approving uh the the vaccine the
coveted vaccine for kids as young as
five years old but you're not going to
believe this video leaked and even some
of the people on the board of the fda
who are pushing this stuff through they
don't know if it works and they don't
know what it could do to children yeah
video we got it believe it or not and
then finally
this marxist communist anti-american
congresswoman ilhan omar who's really
just just horrible i mean she wants to
destroy america her words not mine like
she doesn't like america even though
she's a first generation immigrant from
sudan she has power and money and
influence and all of those things but
she thinks this place is horrible well
because she defunded the police in
minneapolis well now crime is rampant
stores are closing it's just an absolute
disaster there are crimes uh murders up
like the whole freaking thing collapsing
so who's she blaming
the police yeah surprise surprise we got
some video on that uh guys before i get
to any of that i want to talk to you
about shamany you know we've been
telling you about shamany for a couple
weeks now samantha from arcadia
california is raving about her
remarkable results
i love genusl plant stem cell therapy
i've used it all over my face under my
eyes it's cleared up the flakiness even
reduced my far headlines and someone
even asked if i got work done nope just
jen you sell by shaming fine lines
forehead wrinkles dark spots bags
puffiness under your eyes gone right
before your eyes and best of all
guaranteed results in as little as 12
hours so you get your money back it's
that simple now get this genusell has
now sold over a million products yeah
million products lots of companies have
tried to duplicate them and they all
fail it's for both men and women and i
just mentioned in a recent show that
when i look back on my old prageru why i
left the left video i stressed that in
my mind and i had huge bags under my
eyes but no more i look younger now than
i did then even my assistant helen has
been raving about their crystallus
microdermabrasion treatment people all
over the country then try genusell
products they fall in love and they buy
them again and again now you can see the
difference today get fifty percent off
their most popular packages go to
lovegeniacell.com
dave for fifty percent off these are all
of their customer favorites go to love
g-e-n-u-c-l-u-g-e-n-u-c-e-l-e dot com
slash dave to get 50 off order today all
orders upgraded to free priority
shipping from our friends at
lovegeniecell.com
and now back to me should we show that
dancing thing one more time it's so
horrible i can't get it out of my head
one more time
[Music]
ah you know i can't i can't start the
show that way like really throw
everybody into all the stories that way
give me a little trump give me a little
trunk
[Music]
it's just great it was like a dream were
those four years they were like a dream
it's crazy it's crazy meanwhile i always
wondered did trump know what the song
ymca was really about does he know what
those guys were doing at the ymca kind
of makes you wonder but it just goes to
show he's open he's down he's cool all
right
okay so let's talk about ron desantis so
this is the governor of florida who of
course is basically saving the entire
country right now he is modeling for
other governors and for regular citizens
how to stand up for what you believe in
how to defend your citizens how to
defend our way of life and make sure
that an ever-encroaching federal
government which wants every piece of
all of us at this point does not get all
of those pieces uh and fauci has now had
it sorry desantis has now had it
with fouchy who of course just the other
day it has leaked out that the nih under
fouchy was funding research where they
were literally taking the heads of dogs
putting them in a box with these fleas
that were eating their faces off while
the rest of their bodies were left
outside so they couldn't i'm not going
to show you the image again so that they
could not even defend themselves really
horrific stuff and it makes you wonder
what else he was funding well here's
desantis on fouchy no nih gave money
to fund research gain of function
research at the woohan institute of
virology so what they're doing is
they're taking u s tax dollars in china
and they're trying to create super
viruses that'll be more dangerous uh for
humans and they'll say well we want to
figure out how to combat the viruses but
you're doing this this is very hazardous
i think it's unethical to do it
they should have been banned from doing
it but i think they went around the ban
and so we've got to shut that down you
can't have mad scientists running around
playing god like this and then come to
find out what else is fauci and nih
doing they're doing cruel experiments on
puppies
what they were doing with those puppies
is flat out disgusting it's despicable
that needs to stop i cannot believe
american tax dollars would go to treat
those dogs the way those dogs would be
treated and you know i really think
fauci needs to be held accountable these
people these bureaucrats they don't get
to just run wild and do whatever the
hell they want to with our tax dollars
and so from funding gain of function
research uh to treating these puppies
with really
unimaginable cruelty
i think that whole lot of them uh need
to be cleaned out and we need to be
standing up for the american taxpayer
and doing things ethically and not doing
things like gain of function research
and certainly not abusing puppies thank
you
like did any of you watch that and think
man that's a bad dude that guy doesn't
know what he's talking about he sure is
a mean guy he's defending puppies and
he's defending the right for us to know
where our tax dollars are going and to
make sure that those tax dollars don't
go to fund uh bugs eating the faces off
puppies and also this gain of function
research so quickly on the gain of
function stuff you guys all know about
this already but it has come out i mean
it is simply
true and we've played video i've talked
to ron rand paul about it
uh fouchy lied under oath about what the
nih was doing at the wuhan lab they were
funding gain of function research and
there's that very famous video we played
it a couple times i'm sure you guys well
seen it where
rand paul asks fouchy about it and he
gets all indignant and sir you don't
know what you're talking about and blah
blah blah and yeah it's turned out to be
true we now know that it's true so fauci
lied under oath will he pay for lying
under oath i sincerely doubt it as i
mentioned all the time james clapper for
former head of the fbi uh cia lied under
oath uh about you know are we surveying
uh people in the united states our own
citizens and what happened to him he
said not wittingly and now he's a cnn
contributor jack dorsey from twitter was
asked under oath do you shadow bam
people he said no obviously they do so
you can just keep lying under oath and
nothing ever happens to you so nothing's
going to happen to fauci in in a legal
sense would be my guess although maybe
maybe maybe there could be enough public
pressure where finally they would turn
on my guess is though that that probably
won't happen but we shall see about that
but yes we did fund it
there's desantis calling him out on it
there's the dog stuff it's like if you
don't care about humans i know a lot of
people we don't really care about humans
we care about dogs more and i respect
that i'm more of a dog guy anyway uh but
like what was he doing what was he doing
and i get it scientists do all sorts of
weird stuff but that doesn't mean that
they should and whatever it is that he
was trying to prove by have those
beagles faces eaten off while they were
alive and unable to defend themselves it
probably wasn't worth it and i guess the
real question as desantis is saying
is basically
is that where you want your tax dollars
going is that when you pay your
income tax at the end of the year and
you go oh we're funding the government
funding the government well i assume
they're gonna give us roads and we're
gonna have some firefighters and some
cops although not if we live in blue
cities um but also i'd like a few
dollars of mine to go to fund making
sure that dogs get their faces eaten off
pretty sure nobody's thinking that so
desantis is fighting the good fight down
in florida desantis is also offering
five thousand dollars for police
officers from other states who want to
come down to florida and get a job so if
you just have had it with whatever state
you're in or you don't want the vaccine
mandate then i saw a banana's video
we'll show it tomorrow i saw it
literally a minute before we started the
show today of what's her name that
lunatic on msnbc joy reid
basically mocking desantis for offering
jobs to these officers who want to come
down to his state that implying that he
wants sick people so that they can cough
on the elderly and he can kill more
people like that's how bananas these
people have truly gotten so ron desantis
man just keep at it keep at it and i
will say one other thing uh it was a
private dinner so i can't fully give you
his answer but i did ask him during the
dinner it was i don't know uh the event
was probably 150 people to dinner was
probably about 14 or 16 people or so and
it went around and he just took
questions from everybody and i said are
you ready to stand up to the machine i
mean the machine that is going to come
at you with unimaginable things and he
had a pretty damn good answer this guy
is not afraid this guy's not afraid so
we got some hope people that's my point
all right let's talk a little bit more
about uh the vaccines you know i said to
you a few weeks ago i don't want to talk
about kovid that much anymore because in
many ways it's more a virus of the mind
at this point if you've decided to go
about living your life how you see fit
and get vaccinated if you want to or not
if you don't and you take into account
your your doctor's feelings and all of
that stuff it's like we need to move
forward we're two years in already it's
like it's time to move on however
because they keep coming at us with more
crazy mandates and now more
uh attack i would say a tax that is the
right word a tax on children it's like
we got to talk about it to some degree
so
uh in the last day or so the fda has
voted 17 to zero
uh to start okaying vaccinations for
children five to 11 years old well now
some video leaked uh this is the editor
of the new england journal of medicine
his name is dr eric rubin
and i am in no way related to dr eric
rubin i want to make that very clear i
am also in no way related to jennifer
rubin the washington post columnist
these are rubens that have nothing to do
with me i am not related to dr eric
rubin i am not related to jennifer rubin
anyway dr eric rubin is one of the 17
people on the fda panel and they were
talking about vaccinations for children
and this video just leaked and if you
don't think this is mind-blowingly
extraordinary i don't know what to tell
you this is nuts
but we're never going to learn about how
facebook vaccine is unless we start
giving it yeah that's just the way it
goes
we're never going to learn about how
safe the vaccine is unless we're giving
it
he's talking about two children
two children now i want to be clear
there were a couple clinical studies for
kids that were very very rushed through
but that man is one of the 17 people
on the board that is deciding whether
your children five years old are going
to be injected with this stuff i'm not
saying anything bad is going to happen
if they're injected i don't know but
either do they so i'm saying leave it up
to you but these are the people who are
going to want to make sure that if you
send your kid to school or if you send
your kid to the freaking roller skating
rink do they still have roller skating
rinks is that still a thing or bowling
are kids allowed to bowl anymore like
that they're going to demand that your
kid gets vaccinated so this is
absolutely crazy they are admitting we
do not know what will happen until we
inject this stuff into your kids that
was shown i believe live on c-span are
you seeing that on cnn today are you
seeing that on that clown network msnbc
absolutely
crazy and it's just such a long string
of misinformation that these people tell
us you might remember this video this is
from joe biden's town hall not the one
he did a couple days ago with anderson
cooper where he just muddled and
befuddled his way through the whole
thing and yammered and stammered and
it was horrible this is from a couple
months ago and listen to what joe says
about the vaccines and you tell me is it
true or not
the the various
shots that people are getting now cover
that they're they're you're okay you're
not gonna you're not gonna get covet if
you have these vaccinations
well hot damn you're not gonna get covet
if you have these vaccinations that
either was 100 of a lie by the man
pretending to be president of the united
states or the vaccines are not working
as promised you may remember this guy
dave rubin who back in july tweeted out
that vaccine mandates are coming and the
vaccines are not working as promised
that dave rubin guy real right wing nut
bag he got banned from twitter for
saying that then i was able to get
enough public outcry on that that they
admitted that it was an error yeah just
an error uh but yeah that's uh that's
interesting so let me get this straight
we're gonna have to test on the kids to
see what's going on here that's coming
from one of the doctors on the fda board
now you've got the president a couple of
months ago saying yeah if you get
vaccinated you're okay but we know that
not only are people still getting
coveted if they're vaccinated but
they're still transmitting covid if
they're vaccinated but now some fairly
well-known influential doctors are
finally stepping up and saying this
stuff related to the kids cannot go on
uh we've got a tweet here from dr aaron
caharidy he is a professor of psychiatry
and director of medical ethics
at uc irvine he said let the record show
i am convinced that today's decision by
the fda to give eua authorization for
five to eleven-year-old children for the
pfizer vaccine will be seen as one of
the worst medical disasters of the 21st
century say what you want in response
and we'll check back in 20
years okay so i know that some doctors
will be for this and i know that some
doctors will be against it but the point
is there is something to debate do you
not think there is something to debate
while 17
board members
are at the fda are saying go ahead and
just inject it into the kids and then
we'll see what happens that's what
they're saying they are literally if you
have a child that's five to 11 years old
right now i said to david this morning
we don't have kids yet and in a weird
way as
badly as we want kids and we are trying
and it's been very complex possibly
because of uh vaccines related to
surrogates and everything else it's like
in a twisted way i feel almost blessed
that we don't have kids yet because what
a horrific decision you would have to
make if you have a five-year-old right
now and they're saying your kid's not
gonna be able to go to school your kid's
not gonna be able to participate in
society and then you watch a video that
you're not gonna see on mainstream news
and you've got the doctor going but we
don't know what it's gonna do kids
and then you've got to run around and
tell all your friends that and the
teachers and the administrators and
they're going to go oh you're a
right-wing q-maniac you're watching too
much alex jones i mean this is what they
have done to society and until you
really realize that like realize it and
then you can empower yourself on how you
fight these people
and and that may mean you have to leave
where you live you may have to get to a
state that is more associated uh with
the beliefs that you have that is really
the position that we are at right now
but that lunatic reuben okay
that lunatic reuben like i would not be
trusting that guy to be injecting
anything into my children while he's
saying he doesn't know what will happen
until we do it and then we'll see you
know sure uh you know they're gonna get
big eye well everyone's gonna be walking
around one big guy one little eye but i
don't know we'll have to see
ridiculous
just because you're a scientist doesn't
mean you're good okay that's an
important there's the line of the show
just because you're a scientist it
doesn't mean you're good or moral okay
we need to stop worshiping these people
they worship themselves enough we've got
a quote here from quartz a little bit
more on what's going on in terms of
pfizer and the fda board and some
collusion with all of this stuff uh
pharma giant pfizer announced on june
28th that former that the former u.s
food and drug administration
commissioner scott gottlieb would be
joining its board of directors the move
fell in line with a troubling pattern
after their tenure at the fda
commissioners tend to go on to advise
private companies in the pharmaceutical
industry in fact nine out of the last 10
fda commissioners representing nearly
four decades of agency leadership have
gone on to work for pharmaceutical
companies the perception of a so-called
revolving door a chummy agreement
between big drug companies and the
regulators who approve their products
for sale undermines trust in the fda by
the way it will not surprise you i'm 99
sure i'm right on this please check me
uh that scott gottlieb is now a cnn
contributor as well so it's like these
people they move from the agencies
to
media
and they bounce back and forth that is
what they do and we are all basically
being manipulated by them amy b in the
locals chat says speaking of that we are
all beagle puppies in a fouchy
experiment doesn't it kind of feel like
that that's a that's a great point
that's a great point they are funding
stuff that they are telling us they
don't know the outcome and we're all the
beagles right now and guess what it
doesn't end well for the beagles once
they have their faces eaten off they
they euthanize them okay so if you want
these people injecting your children
with stuff and then we'll figure it out
later you know you know we're busy
we don't have time and and the irony of
course is that they are rushing this
through in the most extreme ways because
it has nothing to do with covet it has
to do with control
there we know the numbers i mean if i
have to repeat this number one more time
i may have somebody i'm gonna have
someone just stand next to me during the
show with a frying pan and he can just
whack me over the head when i repeat
myself but the cdc numbers on five to 18
year olds .002 percent roughly 500 kids
and half of them had other things going
on and there's even some doubts in some
of that data that it should really be
much lower than that and that's not to
diminish any of the value of their lives
but if 500 kids in a country of we have
about 350 million people in this country
it's like that's why we have to lock
down the country and kids should wear
masks on their faces for the rest of
their lives and not be able to you know
read human emotion and we should make
them all depressed and by the way also
then you'll just keep them at home more
and they can be on tick tock all day and
all the like don't you see how this is
all connected the puzzle man it's coming
together it's coming together and and we
are governed we are governed mostly by
morons
morons and power hungry lunatics with
the exception of ron desantis i like
that uh rand paul guy i like ted cruz
there's there's a couple others there's
i should have a master list can we come
up with we're going to come up with a
master list do we have a white board can
we get a wipe we have a white board in
the garage all right that's it i'm
whiteboarding it i'm going to pull out
my inner glenn beck sometime next week
maybe i'll do it on friday and i'm going
to write a list
of sane politicians and we'll do it on a
whiteboard that can be dry erased and
you know if you're a politician and you
suddenly go same very rare they usually
go insane we'll put you on the list
that's it we're whiteboarding it put
right make a note on that
all right let's talk about ilhan omar
you know ilhan omar is one of the
members of the squad she is a far left
progressive she's basically a socialist
a marxist a communist it doesn't matter
what word you're using to describe her
she deeply hates the united states
i am not editorializing there she's
telling you she came here from sudan she
is as as a first generation immigrant
she has amassed enormous power she has
come here in essence to destroy this
country she she hates the police she
hates our founding she believes the
place is systemically racist she wants
to overrun with immigrants these are all
her policies right i'm just repeating
her policies with a little bit of extra
juice today um but no i said juice there
not jews she don't like the jews either
but that's something else
well now one of the things that she has
done in minneapolis which she has
wrecked she has absolutely wrecked
minneapolis it is one of the places
where people are leaving nobody's going
honey let's move to minneapolis no
they're getting the hell out of
minneapolis right now well one of the
things that she did in the last year and
a half in the midst of all of this uh
black lives matter and antifa
destruction of cities that you know you
don't really uh talk about because in
polite company you know those are the
good guys when they're destroying cities
she was all about defunding the police
right and of course you all know when
you defund the police that then is the
hint to the criminals to do more bad
stuff so in places like portland and
seattle and new york and san francisco
and minneapolis crime is through the
roof in all of these places literally
every metric that they check murder
armed robberies uh you know the whole
thing like every prostitution everything
that could go wrong is going wrong in
all these cities it's thanks to people
like ilhan omar but you're not going to
believe this she's not looking at
herself
ilhan omar does not have a mirror where
she might go you know i really screwed
this one she's blaming the police
themselves take a listen what
we must also recognize
is that the reduction in policing
currently in our city
and the lawlessness that is happening
is
due to two things
one the police have chosen
to not
fulfill
their oath of office
and to provide
the public safety they are owed to the
citizens they serve
right it's documented
but even before that it was documented
the minneapolis police department is the
most dysfunctional
police department in our state and
probably in the country
man
she is no good
when i talk about these people that
blatantly lie to you that stare at you
in the eyes and lie to you
what can we deduce other than they have
really bad intentions like i don't think
she's an idiot i don't like her but i
will give the devil his due i think she
knows exactly what she is doing so i can
only then deduce from that that this is
a very bad person she is the one that
has demonized the police over the past
two years she is the one who has
defunded the police and she dare say
that the police have chosen not to
uphold their duty
how dare you you're the one that has
demonized them you are the one that has
caused many of them to retire and not
want to work
in these departments in your city
because of your rhetoric
she hates america she hates america
there's just no other way
to say it she wants to destroy this
place and to give the devil as due once
again she's doing it that's what we have
let these progressives do and we gotta
push back but we are pushing back we're
pushing back not only as i said earlier
on the technological side but more and
more parents are showing up to school
board meetings which by the way there's
a extraordinary video of merrick garland
uh getting crushed today because you
know he had basically claimed that
parrots were were domestic terrorists
who show up to uh to school board
meetings to fight against critical race
theory and the whole thing was based on
a bunk note that has now been retracted
which i had predicted about five days
ago i was on jesse kelly's show i
literally made a joke about the piece of
paper that it was written on
anyway
some of the cities are just going to go
down and other people are just going to
build great things i'm on board building
great things and i'm telling you i'm
telling you guys i know this was a
little bit of a nutty show today we were
all over hey you know what let's show
dancing democrats again come on
[Music]
when's the last time
imagine thinking that old man pretending
he's president and that buffoon terry
mcauliffe who's calling the other guy
racist and whoever else was standing on
that stage imagine thinking those are
the people who are going to save you
it's it's
i admire i admire someone who could
think such a thing you're so blue-pilled
that the bliss that you must live in the
ignorant bliss you must live it must be
such a freaking joy to wake up every
morning guys part two of my interview
with dr bryant keating all about science
and the assault that science is under
it's a totally different interview than
than i've done in the past is up right
now it's really really interesting he's
got a new book into the impossible i
really enjoyed it uh as always you can
play along at rubenreport.locals.com
q a tomorrow as i said i'll answer
everything that i can in terms of what's
going on with locals and rumble and
everything else uh and we're back to a
round table on uh friday i know we've
got sean spicer and eric mataxis we're
working on the third guest right now and
you know instead of going out to
terry mcauliffe and old joe biden do we
have is there a video tape do we have
videotape of a certain orange man let's
say a certain orange man dancing and
enjoying himself with the american flag
in the background do we have something
we can do can we do it let's do it
[Music]
young man